foreign
[Music]
s it's a point of contention in our
relationship oh the weather outside is
frightful with not get too deep into it
let's keep it on a light note and not
get
encantative
myself
thank you
like if you don't
suffer any [ __ ] storms or have people
that call you out on [ __ ] then you
become an absolute lunatic and I think
that that's why people you know
I mean look
at Jeff Bezos I don't know what he's
like for real but he seems like an
insane person to me right I'm sure Bill
Gates is probably the same way I don't
know I mean Steve Jobs died but he would
have grown up to be a warlord you know
what I mean
and so as would a view I say that I
always say that I thought I said that
you you said it maybe you said it first
but I I say it as well okay so it's my
idea now thank you I'm the captain now
and um but yeah I think that uh
yeah I I I
um
what were you saying [ __ ] but I got
Bezos yeah but before that crazy
before Lord Steve Jobs yeah but before
that
right I want you to know what I said
before that can you be a better
stenographer when I talk please
oh that's what we need that's what we
need dude no there's no this is another
there's no we here I need we need a
[ __ ] stenographer dude we need a
stenographer for the house imagine I
would realize I was wrong so much can we
take it back it did oh it did I did I
did I did say that all right well all
right well I did you get you got that I
think you might have got that wrong all
right well I'm gonna get a new [ __ ]
stagnographer because you're failing for
every one word I would say on the
transcript how many do you think you
would say there would be like in a day I
would be like back it what did Christian
say last and she'd be like this
thank you
you were late
okay what did she say to before that
[Laughter]
stop
[Laughter]
yeah
um there was that a real laugh
yeah I'm gonna be asking you now 42-1
42-1 words oh
um I say so many words yeah and we made
Calvin and he said more words that's so
cute yeah he says too many words so now
you're gonna do it I do yeah dead yeah
then did you eat the spaghetti yeah I
did it's in his pocket yeah it did
um
so uh yeah I I don't know I just think
that uh
uh oh I was talking about oh that out so
Al Pacino is an example Al Pacino is a
great actor if he doesn't have a
director to direct him he'll just be
like oh yeah oh oh and you're like dude
you're playing a mute what are you doing
right the director because I feel like
the director's like we got out but you
know we're so lucky and then he's just
watching him chew up the scene and he's
like okay I guess I don't know I don't
know and I was like do you have the
scene that's cool yeah can I do one more
can I get another one you know and like
sure sure go ahead and he's just at this
point he's like I want to get props in
here I need wings
so then what what's the difference
between that and then like a Christian
Bale that just like continues to [ __ ]
get him incredible I think that one has
well they both probably have huge egos
but like I think that look I think he's
the [ __ ] though he like never does
interviews yeah he's just like has had
the same wife for like decades Christian
Bale's one of the greatest actors of all
time no doubt but um I think I don't
know I don't know I don't know the
difference yeah I mean yes thank you for
kind of like saying like it's me and
Christian Bale and Aaron and Al Pacino
are contemporaries but well it's like
I'm talking to my husband you Chris
Delia and then we're talking about Al
Pacino and Christian Bale us so that is
the group the three of us
that is crazy we've done a lot of stuff
oh yeah
um so I think that Al Pacino and
Christian I don't know dude there's you
know I don't know really I think that
it's very easy for an actor to be to get
a J uh to get jobs start becoming a star
and then it's not necessarily about the
acting anymore it's more about
themselves
and it's different too like
look if you go see a Nicholas Cage movie
or a or take there's a bunch of actors
like this Keanu Reeves
um uh Denzel Washington is like this I
feel like uh and I'm not talking about
Talent I'm talking about when you're
going to see them do a movie you kind of
know what they're gonna do
Denzel Washington one of the greatest
actors but you kind of know what he's
going to do in movies Christian Bale you
have no [ __ ] idea what he's gonna do
uh there are actors like that Mark
Ruffalo you know what he's gonna do
he's great but you know he's gonna do
right yeah what was that this is Mark
Ruffalo that's your Mark Ruffalo
impression yes that's terrible
to give me people to do impressions of
okay
um
Philip Seymour Hoffman
he's dead
you know dude okay when he was alive
I've never seen
he's a great actor do another one
you're not doing them well you can
literally just do anything I want to do
one that I know okay uh
uh uh Johnny Depp
where's the room
[Laughter]
foreign
parts of the Caribbean or whatever you
don't even know
I just saw it a lot during the trial
yeah memes memes all right so uh okay
that's fine you know what I read today
okay you're jumping around on a lot now
but what no but that's okay
um we'd like to jump
you're on the technical of the octopus I
was reading this somebody that worked in
a mortuary okay and she was saying wow
this is so something that you saw on
Tick Tock that you're trying to act like
you read an article from no okay
uh you know I was reading the other day
so so all right in the background there
was Kodak Black and I oh wait no hold on
I mean oh God
um she was saying that she doesn't trust
any
like she tells all of her friends and
family that like if any female passes
away to make sure that the person that's
like handling her body afterwards is a
woman or someone that she knows because
like she knows so many cases of oh [ __ ]
bro no come on I swear I mean I guess
you know everyone does everything but
that is so wild yeah but just like that
it's common enough that she's heard
multiple stories well you feel like
doesn't trust bodies with her I mean I
understand that but also okay there's
two things that I I have to say about
this number one is Yum no no no that is
not one of the things that's not one of
the 100 million things oh do you
remember Yum Yum Yum Yum from that uh
sword and scale podcast yeah that was a
big kick for us for a while that was
yeah we did sword in scale for a long
time we were listening to him and then I
was on an episode of Sword and scale I
recorded it and you surprised me my
voice is on there yeah you lied he told
me well yeah yeah I told you I wasn't
going to do it and I did do it or no I
didn't tell you I was gonna do it and
then I said listen to this you're like
is that you
yeah
um but what was the uh what was I gonna
say now you interrupt I mean I had two
things to say okay so two things is
um so I got pissed but I got through it
right because you you know I got pissed
I threw it so I'm I'm growing you're
just saying a lot of words so
um there's two things
no I can only think of one of them right
now and I'm pissed again but one of them
is
uh
if you are a mortician
do you think number one
you're a you there's something wrong
with you
first of all second of all if the answer
is no not necessarily can you do that
job and keep continuing to do that job
without getting really [ __ ] up
okay so I don't think you have [ __ ] up
people in that profession is what you're
saying yeah no matter what well I think
that's like the Dirty Little Secret that
we just like to gloss over about all of
life what is that there's another thing
that I have I'll go ahead
that I didn't get to number two okay go
ahead no you can go I can have it in my
back pocket
just that there's so much trauma that
we're like constantly interacting with
and it just like [ __ ] up people
continually and we expect people to not
have these issues yeah but like life is
so [ __ ] I know it really is [ __ ] up
to come out even a little
just a little traumatized is like a
miracle yeah so sometimes you might get
morticians that are just [ __ ] bodies
you know what they say you know what you
know what they say it's a [ __ ] hot
take oh boy
but Jews no like obviously that's
[ __ ] terrible and if that was my body
I would be pissed but like well you
wouldn't be you'd be dead is it the
worst thing in the world oh
okay so yes but here was my second
question she's making a joke everybody
it's horrible yeah but like it's not
murder
you're not actively hurting in a live
person
my second number two thing it wouldn't
be the thing I would protest okay
I wouldn't be chanting hell no don't
[ __ ] dead bodies hell no don't [ __ ] dead
bodies outside of [ __ ] Allen's
Mortuary listen uh the number two is
would it be that bad because you'd be
dead you said I'd be pissed which you
wouldn't be you'd be dead so my whole
thing is like I asked my dad like what
do you want my mom my dad have way
different ideas on what they want when
they die my mom wants a beautiful
funeral uh everyone would be there she
wants [ __ ] to play What a Wonderful
World she wants that song at her funeral
uh by Louis Armstrong or whatever that's
the one who went to the [ __ ] with all
of her diamonds just like Planet yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um
but my dad says I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
dead yeah I don't know I don't care if
you have a thing so my guess my question
is
do you want them what if what if you
knew that when you died a mortician was
gonna absolutely
have sex with you I'd haunt him okay but
you know what's worse than getting
[ __ ] burning and people get burned in
ashes all the time so it my point is
when you're dead it doesn't matter
you're not thinking anything it's for
your loved ones if you knew that's
[ __ ] up well I think that's what
you're protecting it's just like my what
I want for a funeral is what is going to
make my children and my family the most
fulfilled and happy grandkids and
everything yeah and like
like what if so you're saying what it
doesn't have to do with me yeah they
[ __ ] they [ __ ] Grandma after she
died you don't have to you don't really
have to tell that to to Cal's kids
what's that from
oh the um
the the uh no I think it was just math
this or something one of the judge shows
where the ladies yeah
I forget why she did it but um what you
were saying is trauma is so pervasive
and life is so [ __ ] up and what I'd
like to say to that is you know what
they say death is just the moment when
the dying ends
that is just a moment when the dying
ends
that's from the song There's the song
that Ed OG energy is good dude old old
rapper uh Premiere did the beat on that
when he says that's just the moment when
the dying ends and it really really
spoke to me it really spoke to me
for a guy that doesn't like music you
certainly it speaks to me excuse me I've
had a huge headache I need Advil but um
do you yeah oh she's so sweet
I was just the way you cared well this
is just regular Behavior
you're surrounded by
sociopaths yeah just comedians
you if you said you had it
I'm on fire go get it no it's okay I can
get in a little bit we can you know
we'll do like uh you know 20 more
minutes and then
yeah I'm gonna go get out of it and by
that time my head will be screaming
still gonna go to the Post Office and
all that stuff I got a package here but
it's all good this is why you're sad
talk about a hot take dude what do you
mean you constantly anticipate the worst
thing happening
and so it's as if you're living
[Laughter]
you're just anticipating the experience
to be [ __ ]
okay you're anticipating the headache to
get way worse
you have plenty of [ __ ] to do after this
and so you're already dreading it
and so you're you're going through the
bad stuff twice and it may not even be
bad so even if let's say the experience
is good like we go to get the packages
and we take cow and it's like a
beautiful evening and it's a good
experience you have a good experience
but then you made it into a bad
experience before so it like cancels
each other out
hell yes
why do you do that
press the button no are you ready for
life to [ __ ] you
hell yeah
I don't know dude I have to drop that
[ __ ] yeah it's really interesting yeah
but it's just like you're right dude
worrying makes no difference because you
whatever is going to happen is going to
happen
it's like being like
oh God you really opened up a [ __ ]
Pandora's Box for me by asking that and
I do not like it like we were discussing
something last night that you're going
to be doing and like the amount of
things that absolutely will not happen
that you brought up as a possibility
yeah one of them was a porcupine Finds
Its way in my anus and lives there and
has a family good
right because in that porcupine what
would it be like hell yeah
kid you were like anticipating someone
poisoning your parents oh dude I went to
Comic Con as a kid before Comic Con was
a big thing and I want my friend who
invited me there and I was so and his
mom took us and she had the adjoining
room and I made him lock the door so she
couldn't come in because I thought she
was going to poison and that is a real
fear I had
and that's how [ __ ] up I am think
about if that were Cal and he was
sharing those fears with you how alarmed
you would be I called my parents and
they
laughed so hard that I thought she was
gonna poison me she's deeper and they
were in Lake Arrowhead and I was in San
Diego and they they told everyone at
Lake Arrowhead and they were all
laughing and I was like crying I was so
scared oh yeah yeah that's the thing
that was like we didn't know them that
like laughing was maybe not the best
reaction now we have all this [ __ ]
science and data that like
you know backs up yeah I was like Mom
our parents were just free balling it
and the fact that they didn't there's no
internet and [ __ ] they did as well as
they did like hats off to free ball my
free ball and parents you know my uh My
My My My by the way her son my friend
was in the room with me and I was like I
think oh I think Mrs family's gonna
poison me
yeah I was a lunatic dude and I am if
that was Cal how old were you
why was too old I was probably 13.
really I was crazy I was so so scared
about everything yeah if that were cow
yeah
what would you do now that we're not
freeballing that we have a lot of data
and like science backing up our
parenting decisions
well I would just be like well why do
you think this and what is what makes
you think this and then if you had said
what I said I would probably have to
still laugh because what I said was well
we were at dinner and she got a ginger
ale but she said she wanted it with a
Twist and I don't know what that is is
that person
oh
sad and cute so you're doing what my
parents did which is laugh
well you're 42 now sometimes you're not
13. if you're 13 I would be like oh
sweetie really yeah
I would laugh later though yeah yeah I
think I would say like well Calvin uh
that's not gonna happen and then I I
would I would say as a kid how do you
know though I feel like she's going to
and I guess I would say like I can I can
hear that you feel that way but
um you have to ha you know in life
you're going to feel certain ways and
you know it's not about it's okay to be
scared but you know you you need to
being brave is not not being scared
being brave is being scared and getting
through the night and and and I feel
like you're gonna be okay because I know
Mrs Valley and I don't think that's
going to happen that's what I would say
to Calvin
is that good
you're an awesome [ __ ] dad
um
and I always say no matter what we have
a great relationship but if God you
can't count on the future right
no matter what I know that you will
always be a fantastic Dad yeah and I
know that that's not always the case so
people yeah just like in
you know yeah I love being a dad I know
but no I love being his dad yeah no I
think you I do no I I absolutely love
being a dad but the stronger thing is I
love being his dad I mean he is just my
I you know I mean I don't know he's just
I love being a dad yeah and I love being
I just I care about him so much it's
weird it was like when he arrived like
the there was the first really first
time I was forced to feel in a certain
way that I had never felt before and
have my walls down and
not live selfishly because you know and
I'm still selfish and I I work through
it and it's it's hard but like it's the
first time I realize what it's like to
not be selfish right like even just
little things like I took him to lunch
today and he
and I I got him turkey which is what he
said he wanted and I got a club sandwich
and in my club sandwich there's bacon
and I love the bacon in the club
sandwich but I I thought oh Calvin loves
bacon I didn't think about that I know
he said he wants turkey but I'm gonna
take a piece of bacon and put on his
plate and then he ate the bacon
immediately and he said ammo bacon and I
just gave him kind of almost all of my
bacon even though I wanted my bacon and
even though it's just little things I
was like
that's makes me feel really actually
really good to legitimately not eat this
bacon because I know he's having it and
he likes it and I wouldn't
I might feel that way with another
person but I have to make myself feel
that way like it was you or Matt or
somebody that I love I'd be like I
really want that bacon but okay look
they want it maybe they wanted more than
me look at it but I don't do that with
cow with Calvin it's just like oh he
wants it I want him to have it and
that's what makes me happy and I wish I
was like that more with other people as
well but it was Calvin to show me how to
be like that and that's
what a wild thing to feel uh you know
because I think that I was just living
very selfishly for so long
um and I never realized that
that you know because I just thought
everyone should live that way they just
don't do it because they're [ __ ] or
some [ __ ] you know I'm whatever I was
making up in my head if I'm being honest
and um
yeah so yeah I don't know well and the
journey hasn't been Linear by any means
like I think when everything happened
and you got into recovery I
thought that
it was like a quick fix I was like oh
this means that like everything is good
now
and seeing now like the past two and a
half years almost three years it's crazy
yeah
um
like it's been up and it's up and down
always yeah um and I only say that
because I feel like I get
um messages from a lot of women who are
going through difficult things oh got it
yeah relationships you know and on the
surface it just seems like you like
figured it out and in your life you know
like under control in like two weeks and
that's not been the case it is it's been
so up and down you know for you and for
us yeah it's I mean life is you're not
real life yeah and it's not it's not
even though it's linear it's not linear
like it's you know uh it's just
yeah hey that's really artistic how you
did that with your hand thank you you
should be a performance artist
well cut you so deep to your soul
because you thought maybe you'd grow up
and be a performance artist I wanted you
to keep talking about what you were
talking about and not talking about the
other thing I yeah I don't know I don't
know life is real life and it's [ __ ]
hard and uh yeah everyone's a real
person and it's uh you know
we're out there for for you guys too you
know you everyone's going through [ __ ] I
also like there's a there's a thing now
too like my meet and greets like that I
do on the road like many people come up
to me and tell me about the struggles
that they've been through and now that I
am on this you know
sell I try to be as more self-aware than
I ever was it is a it is a wild thing to
hear people's stories with those ears
and to like I think I mentioned this in
my podcast but somebody came up to me
once about recently about
um them uh them having these twins that
were in the NICU for a while because
they were born premium uh prematurely
and my and their and and they listened
to my podcast and my stand up
so much during that time and and they
were like you know they came with me to
meet and greet they were telling me
about their struggles and and how they
they were like it was cool to hear you
know you and and and you made us laugh
and like that
you know I I say to them like I I'm so
uh sorry that you went through that uh
but I'm happy that I was there for you
in a certain way because
um I think when people go through real
pain
uh you know and everybody's not perfect
but when people go through real pain
it's such a relief when you have
something that you can do to take your
mind off that [ __ ] and I never really
experienced that in in in 30 plus years
because I was living
just selfishly and and being
not you know you know now that I've felt
what actual pain feels like through me
and through other people
um
yeah I just my heart goes out to you
guys
if you do feel that way or if you're
having one of those times now or if
you've ever had one of those times yeah
and again it's not like a light that you
just turned on no I know you go through
you know periods where like you're not
yeah you know like you struggle and I'm
not in a good head space I'm not you
know whatever it is but and I and I and
I've thought about too like this podcast
is a lot of work I know it doesn't seem
like it because I'm just bullshitting
every week but like it is like I want to
make it good sometimes I feel like it's
you know it's hard and I'm doing [ __ ]
with you know in my mental it's hard to
perform it's really hard sometimes to
compartmentalize and perform on this
podcast and talk about funny [ __ ] all
the time and I know I don't have to and
I appreciate you guys listening to it
and you know episodes like this is are
fun but
um
you know it's a it's
you know I a lot of the times I feel
there are times where I continue to do
this podcast because I I know people
really depend on it unlike it and [ __ ]
and so that's why sometimes I do this
podcast legitimately so uh and it's not
because I I feel charged to do it which
I do often but sometimes I don't and so
you know
I mean
listening to your iPod right now not
even listening to me
listening to right now [ __ ]
and uh
[Music]
that's good
when Houston was a good singer
we can say that
what else
nothing just thinking about what you
were saying yeah I don't like getting
too serious
I don't like getting too serious I don't
like getting too serious I definitely
try to make jokes afterwards because we
need some levity we need some Liberty
because we need some levity
yeah well you like being serious though
huh what is that about that that's not
true well do you like goofing off right
you definitely like goofing off but you
love getting into deep conversations
like dude you like if you're sitting
around with your friends and you're
having a conversation oh yeah that [ __ ]
will be
deep as the abyss that thing will be so
deep dude
it's so
deep that we can see new species of
marine life dude it's so deep we're in
China it's so deep
it's hot well I'm sure that's why I like
being around you so much because I what
we level each other out maybe but when
you go when you go deep sometimes you go
deeper go here we go again can't we just
do jokes but sometimes you go deep and
then I don't want to go deep really yeah
the other night
is this are we being sexual
the other night when I was oh you want I
wanted to go deep and you didn't want to
go deep yeah yeah you're right you're
right sometimes we do it we surprise
each other and sometimes you do jokes
but I always want to do jokes
I always want to do jokes and we have
that don't we yeah
um that is the best dude I feel like
is another study oh no
well the last one was about [ __ ] dead
corpses so this one should let's try and
top that we were looking up um like I
like studies that begin with they I
don't know yeah go ahead researchers
they were looking at um like qualities
that fortify relationships
um because any anything can break
someone up but it's more like what the
buffers are to save relationships and
they found that having a common sense of
humor and being able to laugh through
seems crucial is like the number one
thing it was like 95 of the couples that
have gone through stuff and gotten
through it had that in common
I'm just what was that I think he
coughed right you coughed
oh that was the dog
Oh I thought that uh one fire coughed
I'll put a little laugh in your face
like about the study this study's boring
like that
um but yeah having that in common with
you what was number two
um I just said 95 it pulled that right
out of my ass oh come on it didn't say
95. I don't know what the 90 I don't
know what the number is oh my God thing
I love that about you I love when people
make up percentages but I tell you that
I'm making it up great but don't tell me
that make lie to me
so I tell someone else and they go I
don't know if that's true
I want that for me so I can feel that
pain of oh she lied oh [ __ ] I'm saying
okay well because at that point it's on
me I can't be like my wife told me to
get that look like a [ __ ] so I'm like
yeah but I just I don't know what what
it was I thought it was I must have
misread it [ __ ] now I'm lying why why
are you like that like why are you such
a stickler for the details when someone
other than you is retelling something
but you don't hold yourself to the same
standard control
control he's got a control problem
he's got a control but ask me if I have
a control problem do you have a control
problem hell yeah
hell
yeah
ask me questions
how great am I they're so great
and cute oh my God
uh who's your favorite rapper
well this is uh Tech Nine oh nice really
he is I didn't know that I love Tech
Nine I think he's the best you know I
love Tech N9ne
the album killer awesome
uh okay that was that was it just how
great am I what was your favorite rapper
what would you like you like what was
your favorite food
I mean I have to go potty no you're
kidding no well we can be done but
what's your favorite food
it seems boring now you said ask me
questions I know but not like that I
know it's good trying to do rapid fire
[ __ ] so be fun at the end of the episode
okay okay what's your favorite food uh
pasta [ __ ] yeah dude I love pasta too
but why don't I ask what's my favorite
food why would you ask you what your
favorite food is no I'm gonna ask you
what my favorite food is oh I see what
you're saying that's a great idea go
ahead guys what are you doing about you
do five what's your ask me what your
favorite food is what's my favorite food
pasta yeah I get that right so now what
uh what's my favorite genre of music
the [ __ ] when you play when you're
getting ready no
um
country
no I know
sad [ __ ] no what hip-hop I know that
okay one for one one for one uh
how many kids do I want
well you won eight
but you don't want to be pregnant eight
times
I'll take that and we're not gonna have
eight go ahead another one um
uh
what is my favorite animal
dog yeah yeah okay if your favorite
animal isn't dog you're crazy weird you
know what I mean um
what's my middle name
Anne
every white girls with no limits and
sweetheart oh oh Michelle I know I knew
that it's actually not now
oh yeah Kristen Taylor Delia that's
sweet so what happened to
um what was my favorite part of our
wedding
uh are vowels no
um
the coffee stand no that was cool though
shout out to [ __ ] Mark bub from oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah uh favorite part of
the wedding me no we were mine what
um dancing with cow oh that was very
scary
oh okay you asked me now
what is my favorite
movie
uh swingers oh good good good do you
know what I think the best movie is The
Godfather no
uh I don't think you'll get it what it's
called its name it's called husbands oh
I would have got it oh you would have
yeah it's my jackets of eddies I don't
[ __ ] know even if you can get it but
I think this is the best movie ever
um what is
uh
uh one of my favorite things to do at
night
eat ice cream and take your pants off
dude watch movies and eat at the same
time yeah yeah
um what's my favorite genre movie
uh Thriller yes you got it
um
how many cars do I want
as many as can fit comfortably in your
house sweetheart yes and also
uncomfortably yes and also I parked them
on the street yes yeah it's very good
yes very good
um how handsome do I think I am
I think you think you're an eight
a nine no I think I'm
uh you know it depends on what day it is
really but you would say yeah I would
say I'm an eight yeah wow I know you
better than you know yourself keep going
what uh if I had one uh
uh on my appearance what would I change
my appearance nothing oh that's pretty
good but I would make my legs maybe a
little longer wider after I met Howie
Harry jouzy Howie Jefferson Harry Josie
dude that guy is tall as [ __ ] and I've
got really long legs and I was like [ __ ]
I want that I want those yeah he's cool
dude oh who is my hall pass if I could
have him is it Jason Momoa that's so
[ __ ] [ __ ] up dude I love that
I love all of that you probably like it
now that he's even a little bit fat or
you like that yeah that's [ __ ] dude
uh I don't know who mine is
uh
uh Jessica Chastain
he's great yeah she's great
she could be yeah could be her all of
your like go-to's are like hot women
over 40. yeah
yeah well you know because they know
some [ __ ] that I don't know you know
what I mean 50 60 90.
um yeah anyway uh all right well that's
good I think we did a good uh we did it
good you know
we did it good didn't we
yeah what I love you oh I love you too
uh and this was fun and that uh wraps
the year up I think probably uh so
that's crazy 2022 2023 is coming up and
uh we will be firing the podcast on full
syllables give a recap of this year
like a general recap of like how you
feel about it and how you feel going
into the new one and I'll tell mine too
you go first
okay
um I feel like it was a big growth year
and forced both of us to like
be out of our comfort and figure some
[ __ ] out
and
um in the growth I think came healing
and I'm excited for our next chapter
it's going to be really fun yeah I hope
yeah I feel like uh
you know I don't know uh I feel like it
was a lot of
resetting resettling
um and we
we feel good uh and this year has been
good and it it I have a lot this year
has been hopeful I have a lot of Hope
for the future
um
and I've been very grateful this year
um so I feel grateful and hopeful for
next year uh in 2023 and I really hope
that you guys have a great year next
year and I will come back I will come
back for this podcast it'll be uh just
me doing an episode
um it might be a little late this next
week but uh in the in the new year but
uh we are uh we're back and firing on
all syllables like And subscribe and
also get tickets I'll be in San Diego in
like a week or two uh Seattle I mean
I'll be in San Diego for a week or two
I've been in a week in a week or two
I've been Seattle and Portland Brea
Improv uh Seattle and doing McCall hall
and then New York New York uh Rhode
Island
Chicago in February and Louisiana and
all that Midland Texas
chrisley.com
get your tickets thanks a lot you guys
well that's it for YouTube if you want
to catch the rest of the episode go on
over to uh patreon.com crystalia and you
can get the rest of the thing with me
hearing Kristen we're doing it in two
parts so uh you know it's either part
one or part two right now but either way
go and catch the full version of part
one or part two by going to patreon.com
crystalia also you can get all the
backlog episodes that come out that have
come out uh full in their entirety and
also every month we do an episode
for patreon that is not on YouTube so
check that out too and all that is just
six dollars so going over to patreon.com
crystalia thanks a lot
[Music]